hi I'm Philip and I'd like to talk to
you today about sequencing antibiotics
so before we get into antibiotic
sequencing I just want to give you a
short discussion of the discovery of
antibiotics because it's something I
feel like it's pretty cool it's cool
because it goes against probably what
you've learned about science and science
class there are some lessons here that
are a little bit different so to give
you the story penicillin was discovered
in 1928 it was the first antibiotic to
be discovered it was discovered by
Alexander Fleming and he went on
vacation and he was known for keeping a
messy lab and when he comes back after a
few weeks he notices that the bacteria
that he had been the cultures of
bacteria that he had been studying had
been contaminated with a mold called
Penicillium and that when this mold had
contaminated the bacteria they had
killed the bacteria everywhere that they
had contaminated them and so he said
okay well now we've got something that
can kill bacteria what do we do with it
so this led to a 15 year process from
drug the discovery of the drug to
designing the drug and getting it useful
so that it could be mass-produced for
d-day 15 years later when it was able to
save thousands of wounded soldiers lives
antibiotics are so relevant though to
modern medicine that I think that we
have to step back and ask ourselves
would we all even be here I know that I
had something called scarlet fever when
I was young twice and that's caused by
this bacterium streptococcus pyogenes
and this is a disease that carried a
substantial mortality rate in in past
centuries and but it's just you take the
antibiotics and you get better now right
the issue with that is that maybe
bacteria are starting to fight back a
little bit we're now starting to see the
rise of antibiotic resistant bacteria
such as MRSA or methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus aureus that resists most
antibiotics that are known and this is
troubling so for example here's an
antibiotic and on a petri dish and
the Mirza has spread regardless of the
presence of antibiotic so we let's
define what antibiotic really means and
I'm using it loosely as to be a
substance that goes in and kills
bacteria where do these come from
well they occur naturally just like the
Penicillium mold that Alexander Fleming
discovered a mold is a type of fungus
and fungi have evolved over time to have
these antibiotics so that they can kill
bacteria they're also produced by other
bacteria so in order to kill bacteria
one example would be a bacterium called
the sillas brevis and that's the
bacterium that we're going to study
today and it produces an antibiotic
known as tyrosine b1 so what is Tyrel
sitting b1 on the molecular level it's a
mini protein called a peptide so this
peptide is really just a short string of
amino acids there are 20 commonly
occurring amino acids and amino acids
are represented either in a single
letter alphabet so the the peptide here
is V klf etc or sometimes there's a
three-letter abbreviation so that's
shown here and these amino this amino
acid sequences valine leucine leucine
and so on so we now have a number of
questions that we asked about
antibiotics now that we know a little
bit about them
the first question would be well their
peptides proteins occur everywhere so
what makes these antibiotics special
secondly we would ask them then how is
it that the bacterium produces these
antibiotics and then thirdly which what
the central question is going to be of
this lecture is how is it that we as
bioinformaticians
sequence antibiotics how is it that we
know what the sequence of amino acids
entire sitting b1 really is and so that
question is what we're going to talk
about today centrally although we're
going to just discuss these other
questions as well because we're
interested in the biology